there's a fuckload of 50 year olds that  think their life is over  I think it's over because they've been  playing for 30 years professionally  they're tired  they've been an accountant for 30 years  they hate it but they don't see any way  out because they don't realize that  there's Instagram live because they  don't realize that there's Facebook  groups because they don't realize that  they can do a blog because they don't  realize they're a great writer and if  they did 14 medium posts they can blow  up and so I'm on a mission to get them  to understand that there's still 30 40  years of amazing things modern health is  people going to be healthy for another  30 years 30 how much [ __ ] you can get  done in 30 years avi you're 14 30 years  ago up held are you Richard  you will [ __ ] negative 7 [ __ ]  [ __ ] was negative 7  [Music]